bonsoir acte 1 scène 2 de notre
opération japon à la différence des deux
journaux qui encadrent celui ci cette
édition est réalisée avec un léger
différé à 20 heures heure de paris les
temps et fait 3 heures du matin heure de
tokyo il nous était difficile d'être
bondée alors pour la plupart des
français le japon c'est un petit peu
l'image de l'avenir l'image de ce qui
nous attend en france dans les années à
venir
le pays tout entier il faut le dire est
un vaste laboratoire pour le futur et
laboratoires parmi les laboratoires la
cité du futur là à tsukuba une
cinquantaine de kilomètres de la
capitale tokyo
on expérimente toutes les futures
techniques de pointe avec un peu comme
une obsession
l'idée d'un robot un robot humain qui
ressemble vraiment un homme jacques
ouverte un genre ce bad revienne de
l'agriculture introduire le cerveau de
l'homme dans la machine en appliquant ce
principe le japon veut devenir le numéro
un de la robotique et de l'informatique
dans le monde
un projet d'une colossale ambitions a
réalisé en dix ans pour atteindre ce but
les chercheurs japonais ont été réunis
dans le centre de recherche de tsukuba à
50 km de tokyo
maîtres de la robotique industrielle ils
continuent leurs travaux pour construire
des robots de plus en plus sophistiqués
il étudie chacun des organes de l'homme
et surtout la main ils partent
d'éléments simples pour aboutir à ce
résultat
voici le résultat de la recherche
fondamentale japonaise cette main
artificielle à trois doigts
c'est une très grande première en effet
cette main artificielle se meut
exactement comme la main d'un être
humain
d'ailleurs chaque doigt à 3 phalange
c'est peut-être dans ce laboratoire
qu'est né le robot hommes de demain ils
veulent passer au stade supérieur
en permettant aux robots d'avoir sa
propre intelligence la vue et la parole
pour réussir il leur faut d'abord
miniaturisés et rendre plus puissants
les ordinateurs actuels sur un
microprocesseur de 5 millimètres carrés
ils ont réussi à introduire 10000
transistors 400 seulement dans la
génération actuelle un ordinateur de la
taille d'une armoire sera réduit à une
pochette d'allumettes soyeux
après avoir copié les ordinateurs
américains nous devons dépasser ce stade
et devenir les premiers nous mettrons
dans dix ans l'ordinateur à la portée du
grand public comme nous l'avons réussie
tour électronique notre calculatrice et
cetera notre avance dans ce domaine est
considérable la société moderne ce qui a
changé de structure et il faut avoir des
idées originales
cela est vital pour le japon mais
également pour le reste du monde
à
pour être à la portée de tous et
ordinateurs de demain devra parler dans
ce but ce chercheur étudie le
fonctionnement mécanique de la parole
chez l'homme qu'ils reportent ensuite
sur un boîtier avec des modules
le but faire comprendre des phrases
entières à l'ordinateur
les japonais réussiront-ils ce pari
lancé comme un défi aux autres pays
industrialisés projet trop ambitieux
estiment les chercheurs d'occidentaux
réponse dans dix ans